à l'heure de fleurir les tombes la
toussaint rime avec larcins difficile
d'obtenir des statistiques précises
il n'y a pas d'infraction propre aux
pillages dans les cimetières
pourtant les familles des défunts ont
souvent en tête
un mauvais souvenir sur la tombe de ma
petite soeur à aider il ya des vols des
casses tous les ans un sommet des choses
c'est sûr qu'un tir l'oeil ses volets
gorge mois la dernière fois ça m'est
arrivé au mois d'avril pour pâques et
j'avais fait une superbe superbe déco et
tout et quand je suis revenue
on m'avait volé mon un beau panier avec
des fleurs dedans on m'avait volé enfin
d'autres choses et c'est pas la première
fois qu'on me vole des choses parce que
même les petits objets on nous les vols
enfin pulsions cleptomane ou vol
crapuleux sont à l'origine des
disparitions souvent le butin est petit
mais affecte grandement les familles
qu'on puisse en fait très mal parce que
j'estime que on a à laisser des
personnes qui sont là se reposer en paix
c'est inadmissible qu'on vient de voler
des plants sur sur une tonne sur une
tente de moi ça je trouve ça horrible
dans ce cimetière quelques incivilités
sont recensés chaque année
alors une caméra rotative sera installé
à l'origine elle devait seulement
couvrir les abords du collège voisin
déjà ça rassure la population
et puis il est important aussi pour les
gens qui auraient l'intention de de
faire ces incivilités de savoir qu'ils
sont filmés qu'on peut les rattraper
je pense que aidant dans sur saint jean
de la ruelle il ya actuellement 33
caméras qui sont installés et on a
constaté que ces incivilités ont
totalement disparu
la vidéoprotection est plutôt rare dans
les cimetières ici elle sera
opérationnelle avant la fin de l'année